presented by Acura precision crafted
performance
retrorockets and about to fire
my name is ever Arthur and I'm the
director of the miniseries I was drawn
to this project mainly because of two
things one is that I always try to look
every day into the sky so that you can
take your place and try to figure out
what isn't not important in your life
when Ron Howard called me and asked me
if I wanted to direct the series he
explained it to me that it was gonna be
with Nat Geo and all of these science
was gonna be involved and NASA was
involved in space which doesn't go he
just got me excited because I wanted to
pay my dual match to Nigeria to the
magazine that made me discover the world
so we don't make sense that now that not
you is pushing twins more dramaa
I would embrace that and help them
create a format page driven by trauma
but it's also science facted so that we
understand that what's going on is not
in the future is not science fiction but
it's the Mars mission starts today it is
happening right now the core of the show
is based on the reality which means that
there is no one space agency in the
world that can achieve the ordeal of
going to Mars
so NASA alone cannot do it they have to
come together with Rose cosmos and with
Jackson and it's happening now as we
speak so it was only organic that we
would cast outside of the box so we had
internationality all over on the core on
the idea on the cast on the crew I was
speaking French with my a B and then
Spencer made me and then English with my
producer so it only reflects the reality
of the mission and of what we want to
achieve with the show to me the
philosophical challenges or what
intrigued me are we allowed to colonize
do we deserve a second chance
are we so special - or arrogant species
or is it in our DNA to go there and it's
a right to strive for life and all of
those conflicts are what's really
interesting me looking forward into into
the see see reason
and hopefully that blend of love and
intelligence can permit and bring
audiences closer to the wonders of who
we are and why are we in this plan
you